okay guys so with the what if series
coming out here in a few weeks i thought
it'd be kind of fun to sort of do some
what-if stories here and there we do
have a whole playlist of what-if stories
some of which are based on the ones that
marvel's done and actually some of them
are ones that we made up
so uh make sure you guys check that
video series down in the description but
in this one we're going to cover
avengers disassembled right i.e scarlet
which kills the marvel universe so
here's the cool thing about this
is that for those of you guys who never
covered or never saw our videos on
avengers disassembled this was basically
a story that brian michael bendis
launched and editor-in-chief joe casada
came up with to basically get rid of the
avengers as they existed in
marvel comics and replaced them with a
new avengers team called the new
avengers ultimately it was it was a cool
story it had some cool moments probably
one of the cooler stories that marvel
did
but the what if series or at least this
what if story is predicated on that
concept with a few small changes here
and there and then like one massive
change once you get towards the end so
much like the original avengers
disassembled story
that you had a bunch of avengers who
were meeting at the mansion and then you
had jack of hearts who was previously a
dead character that basically had the
ability to channel energy and then
detonate
uh basically was resurrected from the
dead by the scarlet witch came to
avengers mansion and then blew the whole
place up while that was going on you had
the
events of tony stark who was in front of
the u.n and then had been tricked into
appearing drunk by the scarlet witch and
then just went on a drunken tirade
literally just lambasting countries for
owing and money and all that kind of
stuff that led to stark industries stock
basically plummeting and then tony stark
couldn't fund the team anymore hence the
reason why the avengers disassembled if
you guys are curious about the main
story itself
i'll have a link to that in the
description as well the main story is
really really cool so make sure you guys
check that out but the cool thing about
this is that you basically have this
kind of cleanup duty that's going on
right where you've got
carol danvers as she existed back then
she was called miss marvel uh and then
of course you have hank mccoy
beast basically of the x-men slash
avengers who's just kind of going
through and analyzing the whole
situation they end up finding
little bits and pieces of of ultron now
much like the original avengers
disassembled story
that vision had basically been used by
the scarlet witch and then sent to
avengers mansion and basically spawned a
whole litany of ultron robots and then
like died right it was it was a weird
thing it was really grotesque when it
happened in the story it was wild and
then at the same time that's going on
much like the original uh avengers
disassembled story
she hulk goes on a rampage now there are
a couple differences here
she hulk went on a rampage in like a
local part of new york i don't recall
her going on a rampage and tearing up
all the different superheroes but again
it's been like a few years since i read
it so i could be wrong but ultimately
this led to like a coming together
of everybody who had ever been an
avenger all to all called together by uh
by captain america
right and so again things play out very
similar to the way they had before but
this kind of uh explanation that we're
given here is actually given to us
insofar as like cleaning everything up
in the aftermath of everything that had
happened now those of you guys who had
read the old avengers disassembled story
one of the things that
also happened is scarlet witch had
spawned a cree armada above earth and
then like all these cree soldiers
started coming down and attacking
everything and all that kind of stuff
and hawkeye sacrifices life in the
process
one of the funny things about this is
that when that originally happened
you didn't know the scarlet witch was
the one behind it you thought it was
just
everything going bad right everything
just going south later on you learned it
was the scarlet witch and that was the
craziness of it but like in the moment
you didn't really know that was
happening and it was
nuts when it took place it was really
really cool but what basically ended up
happening here is a couple different
things the first
is that as they're investigating and as
they're having these conversations and
they're basically talking
that this led to this really this kind
of realization and this this revelation
to everybody
that steve rogers and scarlet witch were
having an affair
that they were basically sleeping
together that yes scarlet witch was
technically married to the vision but as
far as sam wilson was concerned he's
like it always kind of made sense right
i mean like she's basically with an
android and android cannot give her
actual kits but for whatever reason she
found herself growing closer to steve
rogers and then realized steve rogers
could give her kids one thing led to
another and they were touching naughty
bits and so again it all kind of jumps
back
because when this whole thing goes down
it basically looks as though the scarlet
witch has completely lost her mind
because the relationship between her and
steve didn't matter because she
basically confronted steve with like a
kind of manifestation of the red skull
and of course a whole bunch of
soldiers start attacking steve rogers
and all that kind of stuff and then
ultimately magneto seemingly comes out
of nowhere
and basically whisks the scarlet witch
away after doctor strange had appeared
and basically put her in a coma and
essentially knocked her out right and so
that of course was what was part of the
original
avengers disassembled story that led
into house of m where scarlet witch was
basically
taken to genocia and then the whole
events of house of them happened after
that and so the big question they have
here is to kind of track
down things first of all to understand
how the scarlet witch could do
this and so ultimately it leads to carol
danvers and beasts continuing their
investigation
and then tracking down quicksilver right
the brother of skull at witch and asking
the question how do your sister's powers
work we need to understand her powers so
we can understand
how all this transpired and ultimately
the response of quicksilver and
one of the things that was always murky
about her character is he's like nobody
really knows how her powers work right
she can just you know alter
probabilities right her hex probability
power whatever it is affect probability
which is just a really
nice way of saying she can alter reality
and that's true that was one of the big
moments behind
brian michael bendis's original avengers
disassembled story going into the events
of house of m
it's a scholar which his powers had
never really been fully fleshed out you
had these things where like in the early
days she had the ability to alter
probability with her hex powers
and then eventually she meets up with
agatha harkness and agatha the hardness
trains her and it's like she's a nexus
being she's a focal point of all magic
in the universe
okay cool what does that mean we don't
know it just means you can do stuff and
then like you go eventually into uh
into brian michael bendis's avengers
disassembled and it's she can control
chaos magic and that's one of the one of
the crazy things because
you did see stories up until that point
right the idea of cathode taking her
over and different things along those
lines but marvel never fully fleshed it
out
it was just kind of scattered and all
over the place but because the fact that
she can manipulate essentially chaos
magic or at least the explanation that's
given the given to beast and carol
danvers by quicksilver is her power is
somewhere you know exists somewhere
between
mutant powers and magic and it's just
it's a weird thing you know i don't
fully understand it
it leads them to doctor strange that way
they get to doctor strange they fight
some
something there it doesn't really matter
right it's kind of a pointless thing but
ultimately
doctor strange kind of reveals this idea
that supposedly there's not supposed to
be any such thing as chaos magic but at
the end of the day the response of beast
is of course there's chaos magic right
it's just nobody uses it because
it is chaotic you don't know how it's
going to manifest or how it's going to
function now
in more recent years and this is
something to understand chaos magic is
something that had existed in marvel
comics for a long time but like the
scarlet witch
it was never fully fleshed out it wasn't
until the aftermath of uh avengers
disassembled house of m and especially
going into things like children's
crusade in the stories afterwards that
basically chaos magic is the power of
catholic it's this
wildly incredible form of magic that's
so incredibly dangerous but if a person
can master it and use it
they become a multiversal force of
energy and that's why the scarlet witch
in possession of the life force the life
entity and using chaos magic
was able to strip away 98 of the mutant
population's powers
not just in the main marvel universe but
across the multiverse remember that's
one of the things that we talked about
that there was a story that came after
the events of house of m and decimation
where beasts realized it was a
multiversal act where 98
of the beaten population's powers were
taken away across the multiverse and
then like
much later on when you get to jonathan
hickman's fantastic four run
you see a future version of the old man
logan universe and mutants are back
because essentially
everything in old man logan took place
seemingly around the time of avengers
disassembled and uh and decimation house
of m that kind of stuff
that future storyline that you saw in
fantastic four by jonathan hickman takes
place
after the events of hope summers and the
twelve lights when mutants start popping
back up again or really avengers versus
x-men it's one of the things marvel
never definitively says that
it's just one of those things you kind
of figure out as you're as you're
reading comics but also doctor strange
kind of looks at this and says okay so i
know you guys saw me up here
basically defeating the scarlet witch
putting her in a coma and i know you saw
magneto up here but here's something you
also need to look at look at the scarlet
witch's hands and he's like that's the
magic hand positioning she created that
illusion right she created an illusion
that i showed up put her in a coma you
know he's like then she created the
illusion that magneto took her away
and because of everything that had
happened you guys were just happy to see
her gone right so you weren't gonna ask
any questions but the reality is
that's all a magical illusion that was
created by the scarlet witch where she's
at right now
it's probably in genocia and we can't
just run up on her right because of all
the power that she possesses
and using what i guess really is just
chaos magic that if we were to go
running up on it right now
we would all surely die and so what we
need is some form of a plan
we need something that can basically
help us go in and take that place out
you know take her out in that
in that location and so you end up
having beast who actually calls together
a combination of x-men and avengers at
the xavier institute for higher learning
and he calls them all here
because and also has the watcher here he
calls them all here because he's like we
need a plan
right like we need to know what it is
that we're going to do and i have a plan
but i need a guy on our side that can
basically help us figure out what's
happening
and ultimately sam wilson ends up
showing up and sam wilson confirms
exactly what they all thought that at
the end of the day it wasn't scarlet
witch acting alone scarlet witch did all
this at the behest of what was basically
steve rogers that the two of them are
working together the problem is
steve rogers is a master of battle
strategy and that cyclops is the closest
thing they have
the problem is that cyclops is no steve
rogers and so at the end of the day they
have what is in effect a poor man's
captain america in terms of battle
strategy
hoping to go in and win this battle
which you guys can already tell it's
probably not going to end well now at
that point you switch over to jenosha
and you basically end up finding out
that yeah steve rogers has been working
with scarlet witch
and that the whole thing behind this is
that he was the only one who really
understood her right the
vision being a computer being a
synthesis whatever you want to call them
was removed from humanity and as a
result could never truly understand
you know wanda and and the power she had
and how
really dangerous she could be but how
they could also be used for good and
that steve rogers is the one that
figured that out and so ultimately you
kind of switch back over to the the
x-men slash avengers team
and you basically end up having split
into two parts the first one is going to
be a front-facing team that's going to
walk towards the the castle of genocide
head-on right the base of operations
where wanda and magneto and all of them
are at they're just going to go
head on the second team is going to be
accompanied by uh by doctor strange and
is going to basically keep them cloaked
right that not even wanda is going to be
able to pick up on them now the problem
with this is that the fear is like you
know wanda's going to eventually realize
that we're here right because the power
she's channeling is power beyond my own
so we have to be fast and so ultimately
you have this team that kind of you know
really sneaks in
to where uh or at least you know
seemingly sneaks into where wanda and
them are at and captain america picked
up on the fact that they were there
because he knew it was it was the only
thing that they would do the only way
they could actually get in as soon as he
saw that there was a contingent team
walking towards the entrance he's like
okay i was born at night but i wasn't
born last night there's going to be
another team that's going to be coming
in here and they're probably going to be
coming in here through
that window right there and then he
immediately attacks iron man
right immediately subdues iron man and
then from there he's like wanda remove
his armor and then he's like wanda like
take the rest of the team right like
subdue everybody else contain them and
that's exactly what happens the two of
them working together it really is
incredible
it really is a sight to behold somebody
with a mastery of battle strategy like
captain america working alongside a
person with the power of the scarlet
witch is nuts and that's when you end up
finding out the idea of an illusion
created by the scarlet witch
to basically trick the avengers into
thinking that doctor stranger put her
into a coma and magneto had taken her
away that was the plan of captain
america
everything that's happened here is the
plan of steve rogers and the reason why
they're doing this is because in the
mind of steve rogers using the power of
wanda they can wipe all of reality clean
and then fix it right they can basically
set it back to a place where it's a
place of peace and harmony and all that
kind of stuff instead of just a series
of warring factions and the reality is
the other way to pull this off is they
have they have charles xavier now in
reality the only reason charles xavier
is here is because of the fact that in
the original
avengers disassembled and really the
beginning of house of m if we're being
honest with ourselves
wanna took charles xavier and then used
his power of telepathy to scan the minds
of everybody on earth
and their subconscious desires and then
that's why the house of m turned out the
way that it was
why reality was created in that way
because subconsciously that's what
everybody wanted but that's that's you
know it was basically the perfect
reality where everybody got what they
wanted or at least
close to it but ultimately when they
brought charles xavier in here that
charles xavier kind of agreed and was
like yeah i mean i know the ends aren't
necessarily supposed to justify the
means but i mean
this is not a bad plan right it's not
the worst worst idea ever of course
they'd also poisoned him and the
indication here is that wanda's actually
manipulating charles xavier into saying
this right but regardless of the
situation
that it doesn't matter as far as wanda
and them are concerned right it's not
really relevant here that the important
thing
is that ultimately uh they're right and
they're gonna be able to overcome pretty
much
all of the avengers right the biggest
problem with this is that in the middle
of this whole conflict
rogue reaches out and touches wanda the
problem is she touches wanda
while the spell is being cast and so
it's basically an incomplete chaos magic
spell which this is when basically
things start to go awry and captain
america literally screams that he's like
no like
do not stop her while she's casting this
spell but ultimately when she does that
everybody dies right because it's an
incomplete spell right everybody here is
basically killed like dr strange shows
up and he was like what happened like
they're all gone and it's like they've
all basically been wiped out now the way
this kind of wraps up is a little weird
here
in the sense that like sam wilson
basically grabs captain america and says
look man like you know i get wanda's
kind of down for the count right and
here's here's the thing you have to
understand though like
steve rogers you're a broken man like
you never would have thought about
something like this in a normal
circumstance like you never would have
come up with this idea that wiping away
all of creation and recreating it
is the best thing like i don't know what
it was man you being frozen in the ice
or something like that but like your
mind's damaged
your mind is screwed up and so when
scarlet witch wakes back up steve rogers
tries to talk her down
and then he can't right and so
ultimately he ends up basically using
her to focus on the love that the two of
them share and in doing so
wipe themselves out of existence right
and that's basically it everybody else
is actually resurrected so i guess
scholar which kills the marvel universe
and then they all come back and then
it which kills herself but nonetheless
they wipe themselves out of existence
right like they're basically no longer
there and they just kind of leave the
universe or leave the rest of the world
to unfold the way it was supposed to
having said that
this story was ass but i thought it'd be
kind of funny you know fun to cover this
thing i thought it'd be kind of
interesting to cover you know the the
you know what if scarlet witch killed
the marvel universe
it's a terrible story it's garbage it's
probably one of the worst what if
stories ever written in the history of
marvel comics i'm sorry jeff parker a
lot of the stuff you write is great
this was not but uh but yeah no it's one
of those one of those weird things
regardless thank you guys for watching i
hope you guys enjoyed this video maybe
you didn't i don't know
and i will catch you all later peace